with PG you got to guard him close cuz
he can shoot so you got to be aggressive
you can't be too aggressive cuz then
he's going to get the foul call make him
make tough shots what about Luca same
thing Fallon wise don't even dare he's
too smart he plays slow his gears like
he got really good Gears of like going
slow to fast and back to slow to fast
again he's slow but by choice exactly
Tatum I think he finishes really well
he's crafty setting things up like
setting the pick and roll up his in and
out is is nasty so you got any Super are
especially Steph like you're locked in
like he got the ball you're like zoned
in you're locked in like I'm here he
just like look at the was about to
happen he's supposed to be in a corner
but then you like look and his ass is
like kind of in a slot in the wing
you're like how the hell and then like
the ball's like getting skipped you look
over at the bench and the coach is just
staring at you like bro I'm like damn my
fault